I tell people my sister moved out west
your science teacher your husband he
renovate houses you're thinking about
moving but you're gonna waits until the
interest rates go down that's not my
story before I was an Avenger
I mean mistakes
[Applause]
[Music]
a lot of enemies
is called signs taskmaster he controls
the red-room they're manipulated fully
conscious but no choices
I should have come back for you how did
the others are there enough
[Music]
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
again
we're family we fight with you
you won't win of course for the best
but look into the past
okay you got a plan or shall I just say
duck and cover my plan was to drive us
away where your plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
between what the world wants you to be
who you are
I mean my choice
I need I'm running
[Music]
here's what's gonna happen Natasha don't
slouch
I'm not slouching you're going to get
the back hunched listen to mother oh my
god enough all of you I didn't say
anything that's not fair
how's it going everybody it's worn in
this morning we got a new final trailer
for the Blackwood a movie coming out in
May and we actually got a ton of new
scenes and a ton of new information
about the movie which is great because
again this is the final trailer there's
a ton to break down and just a ton of
Easter eggs so let's dive into it if
you're new be sure to subscribe to stay
up to date on all things relating to the
MCU and BlackWidow and to enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or ps4 and I'm picking a winner at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
so the trailer starts off with Black
Widow and Jelena Bulova meeting up after
a long time she starts off by telling
the Tasha what she tells other people
wouldn't they ask about her sister now
it seems like they may be doing a little
bit of retconning in this movie because
natasha does seem very very close to her
so-called family in this trailer even at
the end Melina corrects her posture and
a red guardian says listen to your
mother
so they're a lot closer and more of a
family than we anticipated them being so
that means they either are biologically
related somehow or they're just a lot
closer than they made them out to be
so after Molina gets done talking about
the fake story that she's made up about
Natasha to explain where she is we see a
ton of black vehicles pulling up SUVs
they look like they're probably CIA or
belong to some type of government
association we see a ton of different
military people step out of all these
cars and form around somebody most
likely Black Widow and what this most
likely is going to be is after the
sokovia accords Thunderbolt Ross is
going to be looking for all of the ones
who got away and didn't sign the accords
and they're most likely going to be in
the background of the entire movie we
see a shot of Thunderbolt Ross here
actually clearly he is looking for
Natasha and perhaps something else which
will dive into a little bit later on the
video but no doubt he is looking for her
because she decided to help Captain
America and Bucky get away and we know
that from the events of civil war to the
events of Avengers infinity war she was
on the run the entire time so Natasha
flees away goes back home to you Lena
below this house and says before I was
Avenger I made a lot of enemies and this
is where we are truly introduced to
taskmaster and find out what his
involvement in the story is and even
though Natasha says that she's made some
enemies in the past
taskmaster is a new enemy and we can
tell because Yelina is having to explain
who he is to Natasha she says his
callsign is task master he controls the
Red Room now of course the Red Room is
where they train the black widows
including Natasha and Alina and Yelina
goes on to say that the black widows in
the program are being manipulated they
are fully conscious but are being
controlled and this is going to be the
primary reason that Natasha and Yelina
are going to want to stop the Red Room
so they can save all these young girls
and all future girls that may be pulled
into the Black Widow program from being
controlled and used as weapons as they
were as children now this actually ties
into a Falcon and the Winter Soldier
plot detail that we got not too long ago
and the plot detail was that the new
Captain America u.s. agent John Walker
is given a super soldier serum but the
serum actually ends up controlling him
this is a major detail because we saw in
the other Black Widow footage that we
got she was holding those red vials
which is most likely a Super Soldier
Serum and this is going to be the serum
they used to enhance them but at the
same time we've learned that it also
controls them so that pretty much
explains that mystery vial that we were
talking about and this is probably what
Thunderbolt Ross is trying to get his
hands on as well since the Incredible
Hulk we know that Thunderbolt Ross has
been trying to experiment with super
soldiers and trying to get his hands on
a serum we've also heard that the
Thunderbolts and Red Hulk are going to
be introduced in the MCU relatively soon
and since we see Thunderbolt Ross in
this trailer I would say that he most
likely gets his hands on one of these
serums and that's what's eventually
going to turn him into the Red Hulk we
see a scene with Elena on the table it
looks like she's about to get something
injected into her this is most likely a
mind control serum as well so there
could be a potential plot twist at the
end that Yelina is actually being
mind-controlled not that she's bad but
she could be on a mission because she is
being controlled so Natasha says we have
to go back to where it all started so
they can never do that to anybody again
and again that's referring to the
children and the women that are in the
Black Widow program so she goes back and
we can tell that taskmaster just sends
everybody against her and Natasha asks
her sister how many
others are there in Yelina answers with
enough so it looks like taskmaster is
going to send the whole entire Red Room
against Natasha to try and stop her then
we see Alexei szostak ah've aka red
Guardian breaking out of prison and the
family gets back together we see him
next to Molina and Yelina
and he says we're family we fight
together and he's fully dressed out in
his red Guardian outfit and then the
next scene is him taking on taskmaster
and we see a lot here now if we go back
to the beginning of the trailer we can
see taskmaster looking at footage of
Black Widow fighting this is what
taskmaster does his skill is that he can
manipulate anybody's fighting technique
just by watching them so he can mimic
not only black widows fighting style but
any other avenger that he might have
seen and we see that in this trailer in
the beginning when he's holding the
shield he's clearly mimicking Captain
America's fighting style we then see him
fight red Guardian and he pulls out
claws and his finger tips just like
black panther identical to his and while
he's fighting red Guardian he's
spider-man kicks him does a backflip and
lands just like Natasha would land so
it's been revealed and we can clearly
tell that taskmaster knows how Natasha
fights because he's been studying
footage of her and since he's been
studying footage of her he's definitely
looked at footage of all of the other
Avengers fighting styles as well and now
he can fight just like them so it's
almost like Natasha is going to be
taking on all of her other fellow
Avengers their fighting styles at least
in this movie including Hawkeye there's
a scene where Natasha and Yelena are
trying to get away
Natasha seems to be driving pretty
poorly as you Lena tells her that her
plan sucks but then we see taskmasters
tank a huge armored vehicle shows up and
we see taskmaster pop out of the top of
it with a bow and arrow in hand just
like Hawkeye so again it's kind of like
she's fighting her friends all of the
Avengers that she's fought alongside
with over the years and that's kind of
going to be the point of taskmaster
being this villain we've heard Natasha
say in each one of the trailers and TV
spots that we've gotten so far for this
movie that she was an Avenger she went
off and she got a new family and in this
movie she's going to have to team up
with her old family to take on
taskmaster who fights like all of the
Avengers now there is one key scene here
at the end of the trailer that we have
to talk about because it is important
Alexey in full red Guardian uniform
which of course
is the Russian version of their Captain
America he kicks up taskmaster shield
just like Steve Rogers does and he
throws it basically through the window
of a Helicarrier that taskmaster is
trying to get in and in this scene if we
slow it down we can clearly tell that
Malina is the person who is piloting
this Helicarrier and this is important
because it was widely believed that
Malina is taskmaster that she is the one
that is actually in charge of the Red
Room and this seems to be the first
scene that we can clearly tell that
taskmaster and Malina are in one scene
together so although it is still
possible because in the comics there are
multiple versions of taskmaster it
doesn't seem likely that Malina is task
master we end this with an awesome scene
between Natasha and taskmaster fighting
where he pulls out a sword and he kind
of does this in a way like Natasha pulls
out one of her batons so again she's
going to be fighting taskmaster and he's
going to have a lot of different
fighting styles but he's going to have
her fighting style
so this movie is going to have a ton of
action a lot of hand hand combat a lot
of shooting and overall looks absolutely
fantastic and I can't wait for it to
come out in May what do you think about
this trailer let me know in the comments
down below and let me know who do you
think taskmaster is drop your answer
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe notifications turned
on to stay up to date on all things
relating to Black Widow and the MCU
don't forget to follow me on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof